jean vous avez 45 secondes inquiète pas
merci beaucoup je voulais simplement je
dis d'accord avant à mes
collègues cabaret j'ai essayé d'avoir
une intervention parce que nous sommes
tous les deux des responsables qui soit
équilibrée c'est moins d'une minute quoi
ces gens
vous savez je suis je suis allé au
series et par mon oreillette jeux
peuvent aller de rien du tout ce sont
les bienvenus là
il me prend un témoin devant tous les
jeunes à qui nous regardent est ce que
vous pensez le chéneau loquay c'est une
manière d'apaiser ce que j'appelais de
mes voeux je ne passe pas être passé
pour le plus taciturne est le plus
triste des pires à des porteurs de
nouvelles de l'assemblée au contraire je
suis connu pour leurs cornes pour le
contraire je trouve la manière dure et
méritée justement dans une réunion et
une rien n'apaise va bien de ne pas
avoir ces propos et quand est ce que
vous avez eu à l'égard de dominique moi
j'ai trouvé c'est pas très élégant ni
talent et ainsi le savoir devant
quelques uns une pièce assez ne pas
avoir autant ce n'est pas comme ça que
vous ramènerez je ne sais combien de
millions de français 5 millions le divan
sur le sentiment qu'ils sont passés par
contre ce n'est pas là la cause ce n'est
pas par leur faute que les cancéreux ne
peuvent pas et hop et en talent là je
regrette il d'autres raisons et ça c'est
trop facile et ça ça n'a réuni par les
français moi je le message est passé il
faut pas s'arroger des compétences que
l'on n'a pas et moi j'écoute le corps
médical merci et la vie j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir dans la vibration serrières
l'humilité de fait j'aime beaucoup
d'humilité tout ça